Oh am i what happened did it burn oh
wait I do uh uh uh sure whoa 72 hours
ago I arrived in Mumbai India
smack bang in the middle of monsoon
season the plane skidded out in the
landing strip in our cab almost drowned
with us in it
the driver was praying the entire ride
I waited for a full day for it to stop
raining so coming up to the roof to
reveal this week's Eid
welcome to much suit season in Mumbai
India if you're confused as to what the
seed envelope is that's totally cool I
built this global map which you can find
are not normal show.com
where you plant a seed which is an
unfinished idea in your city each week I
choose a new scene I fly to that city
and completed with you basically how it
works is I go through the seed map which
by the way has so many incredible ideas
if you ever stuck with an idea make sure
to go to the seed map and check it out
and just scroll around and I'm sure
something epic will spring - thought how
I do it is I scroll around until I see
the most compelling seed that makes
sense to me then based off a pure
impulsive creative flow state if you
will
I then contact the cedar fly to your
city and create a foam with you in a
week it's that simple
the seeds that have turned into films I
make pink if you haven't gotten to the
mouth to plant your seed please go to
nod normal show.com and plant your seed
now the sweet see
is together we should turn the ordinary
into the extraordinary viable model
welcome to my new weekly show not normal
service brainy you've secrets they're
sweeter flashy not the switch mystery
say gets his facts
Mumbai India is like being on a gigantic
phone thing it feels as if everything is
just being pulled off a mini second data
and you'd be in the wrong place it's
like perfectly synced chaos
you can't force anything or control the
outcomes of your objectives you just
need to let go yet something I need to
get better at
it was time to meet a man and talk about
[Music]
oh my god I cannot actually believe that
we are walking together in Bombay I've
lived in Bombay all my life and I've
seen so many people come and go myself
consider leaving to like the life here
becomes mundane after a point that sighs
is chaos you see exactly why I want your
help to turn the ordinary into
extraordinary from your perspective I
don't know exactly what that entails but
I'm sure with your help you can make
something awesome among is this quirky
Indian view a great description of brew
so accepting curious and on a mission to
raise positive awareness about his city
he came back to my place and
reconceptualize we spoke for hours about
different beliefs and interesting facts
about the Indian culture like when dogs
are bought in a plain sight it's
believed that they were ghosts present
cricket is a religion and our chess
buttons shampoo plastic surgery pie the
mathematical value algebra trigonometry
and diamond mining were all invented in
India
then fell asleep on my couch the next
morning the idea came to me brew I got
the idea to do super ambitious for 24
hours it's so much media coverage around
but you would pick its stars right
felicitous it's awesome
but like anywhere else in the world
nobody celebrates the ordinary the daily
unsung hero yeah and that's what I want
to do is turn the ordinary into the
extraordinary you know add a voice or a
delight to the daily unsung hero
utilizing dye Jetix our dye Jetix arms
are the actual sounds made by something
captured by a device in my case being a
camera sounds belongs for the objects we
attach them to right it's all about what
she's experienced before when you hear a
sound without seeing the source you
immediately attached it to a visual in
your mind what I want to do is link
people with a rhythm of sounds make
music from the cbz order you just doing
the daily routine the everyday unsung
heroes that make Mumbai moon an anthem
for Mumbai
I have like a really special close
relationship with sounds because I've
got really sensitive yes like my parents
used to say to me that I've got a
superpower that I never use because I
never listen I never used to listen but
now now I've started to really like kind
of harness that I would really really
like to know exactly how it works if it
will show me
okay broom it's important is you can
hear how many sounds there right sounds
like chaos and you just need to focus on
one thing you know put your head back
just close your eyes and just try and
join in you know isolate the sounds
alright yeah yeah
[Music]
needed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
better than in Connecticut you like that
yeah
the not normal show has me traveling all
around the globe connecting with
like-minded people on seeds that become
my weekly uploads and if you're thinking
that's a lot of flights
it's nothing in comparison to the amount
of Wi-Fi zones I'm constantly moving in
and out of and as you know that can be
super dangerous you see I've been a
victim of something called phishing once
before where someone in an unfamiliar
space on one of my travels disguised
themselves as a trustworthy entity
online and got ahold of my personal
information
a few usernames and passwords which was
really scary and and felt completely out
of my control and out of my circle of
knowledge luckily and all got sorted out
and a good friend of mine recommended
that I try out expressvpn that
effectively encrypts my internet data
preventing others from sniffing my
information when using Wi-Fi networks in
hotels cafes airport lounges or wherever
I need a hotspot when I'm around the
globe without a VPN you're really
putting your personal information in
danger expressvpn makes me feel really
safe and even better it's really easy to
use just one click and all of your
daughter going in and out of your
computer is encrypted and protected by
expressvpn get three months free with
them on a one-year package that's less
than seven dollars a month and they have
a 30-day money-back guarantee visit
expressvpn comm slash dan mace to learn
more other than that don't forget your
awesome brew and I'll see you next week
Wednesday
I just want to say a huge thank you to
my sponsors vnh for the awesome gear
epidemic sound for the insane library of
music and skill share the online
learning platform for creators there's a
link in the description to get a two
month free trial and don't forget to
subscribe to catch next week's episode
where we getting seriously deep in
Bollywood
[Music]